on en vient maintenant à cette série d'
enquêtes que nous lançons cette semaine
elles concernent la vie sexuelle des
français en 2010 avec cette question en
quoi at elle évolué ces dernières années
premier volet ce soir les jeunes les
adolescents est l'un des principaux
enseignements vous allez le voir alors
que la sexualité n'a jamais été aussi
exhibé c'est que les choses n'ont pas
tant changé
les adolescents ne sont ni plus précoce
ni plus imprudents que leurs aînés
reportage nabila taboury philippe berre
rouler une pelle un patin se bécoter
bref emballé chez les ados les premiers
émois amoureux passent par le baiser
c'est vieux comme le monde sont pas
toujours dans le même sens c'est mon
style de roulage de pelle idrac beaucoup
mais on ne conclut pas forcément car
contrairement aux idées reçues qui tu
feras tu saute dessus comme ça en france
l'âge du premier rapport sexuel n'a pas
beaucoup varié depuis une trentaine
d'années pour les garçons il est de 17
ans et deux mois pour les filles il est
de 17 ans et 6 mois dans les années 40
la première fois pour un garçon c'était
18 ans et pour mon fils était 22 ans qui
fait les david ont 18 ans un peu fleur
bleue ils sont surtout très amoureux ça
fait un an et demi qu'on est ensemble et
puis bas depuis un mois
c'est l'amour fou ce set bonheur c'est
la joie et les deux tourtereaux ne se
quittent jamais au lycée ils sont dans
la même classe de bac pro vente
leur histoire a commencé un jour de
rentrée scolaire par un coup de foudre
je vais les couples à même son petit nid
le studio de david au fond du jardin de
la maison familiale entre eux beaucoup
de tendresse et d'attention une
complicité qui leur permet de parler de
sexualité sans génie table une première
fois vous l'avez vécu un an
voilà non moi oui voilà à 16 ans c'est
jeune donc j'aime à badghis aideront la
preuve je suis senti à l'aise et comme
sur des roulettes une relation sereine
épanouie qui d'après eux les fait
grandir
mais la belle histoire peut aussi virer
au cauchemar
julie a 17 ans et demi lors de son
premier rapport sexuel c'était en mars
dernier avec un garçon plus âgé il n'est
pas représentatif
moi je prenais pas la pilule je n'ai pas
comment ça marche pro vandières docu tu
lui a valu qu'il fallait qu'il mette un
préservatif
bah si j'ai dit mais le imaginantes
c'est la première fois ce programme
julie se retrouve enceinte elle décide
d'avorter sans en parler à ses parents
trop peur de leur réaction
depuis la jeune fille refuse toute
relation sexuelle j'ai perdu recommence
je veux pas que d'avoir une over pour
une nouvelle expérience comme ça j'ai
j'ai une gallerie tout seul donc le
nombre d'interruptions de grossesses
chez les jeunes filles de moins de 18
ans ne cesse d'augmenter
8000 dans les années 90 quinze mille en
les contraceptifs sont chères et il est
souvent difficile pour les jeunes de se
les procurer anonymement
quant aux informations les ados on
dispose mais ce ne sont pas toujours les
bonnes alors combien de temps peut durer
un rapport
elle les questions sont directs elles
ont toutes été écrites par les élèves
limites et qu on prend le temps qu'on
veut quoi par contre on l'enlève camp
depuis plusieurs années maintenant cette
infirmière scolaire et ses collègues
organise des séances d'information au
moment où il va éjacule y voilà c'est un
des obstacles aussi à la l'accès à la
contraception des jeunes les jeunes en
fait ils ont des difficultés à parler de
leur sexualité à leurs parents parce que
les parents ce sont les parents et que
eux n'ont pas envie d'aller dire à leurs
parents justement qu'il commence alors
une vie sexuelle et qu'ils vont avoir
des rapports sexuels
et c'est tout le paradoxe d'un côté rien
n'est dit de l'autre la sexualité sexy
parc avec internet et le développement
des vidéos depuis une dizaine d'années
les jeunes sont de plus en plus exposés
à la pornographie à 14 ans 61 % des
garçons ont déjà vu un film porno les
filles sont 45% qui a déjà vu un support
de tous élèves de 3e benjamin lume guen
et gabriel ont entre 14 et 15 heures
[Musique]
fait appel - l'internet c'est leur monde
virtuel où à chaque clic ils risquent
une agression visuelle elle bien réelle
personnellement je sens que c'est parce
que entre la télé avec ses numéros
et puis la tête avec les images au
risque de déformer leur vision de l'acte
sexuel
non mes voitures lourd au comptage des
voix il ya des gros lourd qui prennent
défi pour les deschiens et doué c'est
celle où ils ont saisi des vingt deux
comme des objets quand on vous dit
encore qu'on proposait pas la vraie vie
dans la vraie vie typhaine et david
notre bébé qu'oublier déjà une histoire
sans nuages une relation consommer pour
au s'exprime avec amour ils ont
d'ailleurs déjà choisi le prénom de leur
futur enfant